funny enough
uh in my in
deep investigative journalistic research
of you yeah says you're you're used to
be an MMA reporter yeah how how how did
that happen how did you get into it I I
was really into martial arts I was like
a huge UFC buff I mean this is
plenty ten maybe did you practice
martial arts yourself I did yeah I was
mostly stand up I did like um I did a
lot of Muay Thai and then some Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu and just yeah I was really
the thing is I I get really intense
about my hobbies
into it I was all in awesome and
um I had worked a little bit as a
journalist and I was like oh I should
like
do MMA reporting
and I emailed uh this uh MMA website in
Sweden I was like hey can I come and
write for you and they were like oh
actually we're going to an event in
Gothenburg tomorrow do you want to come
yeah and I was like wow this is a lot
it's like 11 p.m at night but sure I'll
come and I went there to their office
I'd never really met them and I'm like
this is kind of scary like I'm a 20 year
old girl and going there in a group of
men with a group of men and
um they were so rude
they'd like I went there and I was like
hey what's up and they were all kind of
ignoring me and just like not looking at
me or interacting with me
until they realized that
Simon was a girl because we'd only
talked over email and they're like oh
this guy named Simon is Gonna Come and
then they were like oh [__] Simon it's
actually Simone yeah and it's a girl uh
so I kind of like slid into that in a
very very strange way and I did that for
a year but then I got kicked out of an
interview with Alexander Gustav song and
uh pronunciation is so good
and then I just kind of never went back
and I was done with it and now I'm not
allowed to do martial arts because of
brain stuff so I've kind of put all of
that behind me and it's it's interesting
it's like I definitely see the
athleticism in it and the skill that
goes into it I think as the older I get
the more concerned I am about the health
impacts of the sport and of the people
who are practicing it on an elite level
and I'm just not as
um
cannot as the 100 just here as somebody
beats somebody else up into a pulp yeah
especially considering the effects you
might have on the brain may I ask why
you got kicked out yesterday is anything
fun so embarrassing what happened it
wasn't I didn't it was not I didn't
intend to get kicked out I didn't
realize I was going to get kicked out so
it was Alexander Gusto song was going to
fight Jon Jones yeah and he had just he
was kind of like this Golden Boy in
Sweden and he had just come out to the
press that he had actually been to jail
for violent crimes
and all I wanted to ask all I asked was
what was the reason that you wanted to
bring that forward now
and apparently that was completely like
blacklisted but I hadn't gotten briefed
about it at all and the
um the pr man had a PR of the UFC was
just yelling at me and they kicked me
out of hell in Stockholm and I
immediately called my mom and I was like
Mom you will not believe what just
happened I got kicked out of an
interview at Grand Hotel
because in the 90s she got kicked out of
an interview with Mel Gibson from the
gun Hotel so that's like runs in the
family so I was just like she party so
yeah no it was just this weird
generational skip where we both gotten
kicked out of interviews at this same
Hotel